well this is ultimately how I was able
to grow my YouTube channel while I had a
full-time job so imagine being able to
create seven videos all in one sitting
so now that if you were going to upload
one a week you would be seven weeks
ahead on your YouTube calendar so how do
you do this step one plan your videos
beforehand I've learned that it's very
difficult to plan your videos and shoot
your videos in the same day it's almost
like two different sides of the brain
one is kind of a research writing
analytical side and then the other side
is the kind of creative extroverted
actually needing to deliver the content
even if you're alone talking to a camera
in your bedroom or home office and so I
actually am doing a batch of content
right now and I planned out today's
videos on a Google doc over the last
week or so maybe in a four hour block of
time and then another one hour to polish
eight different videos so I can sit down
today and record them all all in a row
and when you're planning your videos you
want to make sure you define your title
I actually like to know what my title is
ahead of time my title for this is work
smarter not harder how to create
multiple YouTube videos in one day so
going into the video I know what the
title is what is the topic you know the
title and the topic and even an idea of
what the thumbnail could be now when you
plan ahead you also give yourself an
advantage by selecting topics that have
the biggest opportunity of getting the
most amount of views for example we talk
about our asq strategy answer specific
questions and if you're actually
interested in topics that get the most
views on YouTube let me just point you
to our free class at thinktubeclass.com
I teach three Surefire video ideas
guaranteed to get views and that is some
very important information when you're
planning out a batch of videos If you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to tube 1K challenge dot com to
join our next live YouTube challenge
you'll learn our best tips and
strategies that are working here at
think media and I think you'll love it